[Music]
our team coverage continues the cyclist
community is reacting to news of this
terrible incident joe moeller joins us
live after speaking with one man who was
part of that cycling group
joe well news of this crash spread very
quickly within the bicycling community
now that one man who we did speak with
who was in this group on the 95 today
says
tonight he's still trying to figure out
how this all happened now this group
of about 18 he says does this ride every
single year they call it the nipton loop
the man who was riding with the group
says
it got windy and next thing they knew is
around seven bicyclists were stuck
between a car and that car that assists
riders
and the box truck in an emotional
interview michael anderson told us it
was a horrible scene
he says trying to contact his friends
families has been difficult
i've been a cop for 22 years i just
retired last
month for metro police
and i've i've seen stuff
obviously as a police officer
public service and
between it's your friends i never seen
that
according to the national highway
traffic safety administration there were
857 bicyclists killed in
2018 in america now the bicyclist
community is tight here in southern
nevada we stopped by a bike shop
where people there were shocked about
this crash many say they were texting
friends trying to find out who exactly
was involved we were told that this
group that was on the 95 earlier today
were experienced riders and they were
going pretty fast
this did happen we were told that riding
on roads like this like this highway
can be scary and very dangerous and this
is something that they all hope
never happens 8 news now